كنت تذكر هناك اشتباكات قويه وعنيفه لا
سما في المنطقه الجنوبيه وهناك ما تصفه او
ما وصفته صحيفه فورين بوليسي غياب
الاستراتيجيه الواضحه للمعركه من قبل
القياده السياسيه وسم تحديدا بنيامين
نتنياهو تقول فورين بوليسي ان نتنياهو لا
يملك استراتيجيه واضحه لاداره ما يجري
سواء في جنوب او في وسط او في كامل مناطق
قطاع غزه وايضا في الحديث عن الاشتباكات
وعن المناطق هناك خانيونس تبقى منطقه
اشتباك وايضا كامل المنطقه الشرقيه
المحاذيه للحدود للخط الحدودي القوات
الاسرائيليه ما زالت متمركزه عند نقطه
تسمى البلديه في منطقه خان يونس تتجمع
فيها المدرعات ومن هذه النقطه تشن عمليات
توغل وفي كثير من الاحيان كما حدث صباح
اليوم استعانت بالطائرات ال المقاتله
لاستهداف مواقع داخل مدينه خان يونس وايضا
قامت او نفذت تفجيرا كبيرا جدا في المدينه
ادى الى انهيار احد الابراج في هذه
الاثناء الهجمات في المنطقه الشرقيه لا
تزال مستمره المنطقه الشرقيه نسمع الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بانها قد تكون منطقه
التركز الكبرى لما تسميه انفاق حركه حماس
دفعت احدى او احد الالويه في هذه المنطقه
لواء متخصص بتفجير الانفاق لواء يا هالوم
وهو لواء هندسي مقاتل ولكن ما قالته
الفورين بوليسي بان الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي
يعتمد بشكل عال على الوسائل التكنولوجيه
الحديثه روبوتس وايضا طائرات مصيره
وطائر ومجسات يمكن ان تخترق او تعطي فكره
عما قد يكون موجود في الطبقات الدنيا من
سطح الارض قال هذا او قالت الفورين بوليسي
ان هذا لم يمنح الجيش الاسرائيلي افضليه
ميدانيه بل على العكس قد يكون اعاق قدره
الجيش الاسرائيلي على لعب دور المهاجم
وقالت انه على الاغلب يقوم بدور المدافع
وهذا ينقلنا الى استهداف عربا كانت تنقل
جنود في المنطقه الجنوبيه من قبل كتائب
القسام وادت الى ايقاع على الاقل خمسه
القتلى ولكن الحديث عن القتلى نشير حوله
لوجود تضارب بين الجيش الاسرائيلي وبين
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي هناك تضارب من حيث
الارقام واين وقعت هذه الارقام ايضا خمسه
او سته في الشمال في تفجير المدرعه او
خمسه او سته من الجنود والضباط القتلى في
المنطقه الوسطى
بانفجار شاحنه كانت تحمل متفجرات على ايه
حال ما تزال المنطقه الوسطى موقع عمليات
كبير ونحن ايضا ما زلنا نتحدث نصرات
البريج المغازي والزوايده اليوم اضيف الى
هذه مناطق الاشتباك منطقه جديده بلده
المصدر بدات القوات او قوات الاحتلال
الهجمات فيها قليلا الى ناحيه بين الى الى
ناحيه ما بعد خط صلاح الدين هذا هو خط
صلاح الدين بلده المصدر و بالتالي يبدو ان
هناك من جديد محاوله كما حاولوا مع البريج
والمغازي لتطويق من الجهات الاربعه هناك
محاوله ربما لتطويق الزوايده او فتح جبهه
جديده باتجاه البريج هذه المنطقه دانييل
هاجار المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي قال
انها تشمل المرحله التي انتقل القتال
اليها من قبل قوات الاحتلال ستركز بشكل
خاص بحسب غاري على المنطقه الوسطى
والمنطقه الجنوبيه واصفا اياهما بانها
معاقل حركه حماس بالتحديد وفي الشمال
سيستمر القصف والاستهداف عند اكثر من نقطه
في هذه المساله نختم الصحف الامريكيه
بالتحديد توجه لوم لطريقه اداره المعركه
من قبل قوات الاحتلال تقول ان استراتيجيه
التدمير الممنهجه التي استخدمتها القوات
الاسرائيليه قد تكون احد الاسباب التي
تعيق انجاز ميداني كبير في وقت تساءلت فيه
ارتس وهذه النقطه الختاميه ما اذا كانت
اسرائيل محمد ستتمكن من تحقيق ما سمته
هارتس بالنصر الميداني